et on accueille maintenant pour l' hyper
v ou suivante on accueille jacques
toubon
jacques mangon soir frédéric beigbeder
l'écrivain dont tout le monde parle en
ce moment vous connaissez astrid veillon
dont la carrière est en train d'exploser
avec le 7 juin un téléfilm et roger
hanin qui est un remake de la femme du
boulanger où elle joue pomponnettes la
nouvelle accent plus beau mais moi je
viens du sud via nice donc bruyerre noah
ici présents yvan le bolloc'h et laurent
ruquier qu'on ne vous présente plus bien
entendu je suis jamais rencontré
monsieur toubon que vous parlez beaucoup
de lui quand même tous les matins en ce
moment non non il est plutôt calme
il a eu six années animé la sécu l'ip
tranquille en y avait 3 qui est bon donc
jacques toubon vous êtes maire du xiiie
arrondissement
alors ce plan politique c'est de
conseiller politique de jacques chirac
ou de l'époque partie du conseil
politique du rpr c'est exactement la
même chose et c'est plutôt ça c'est
plutôt je fais partie des instances
dirigeantes du rpr alors voilà je ne
sais plus mais je ne vais plus à
l'elysée
vous n'êtes plus à l'élysée d'accord je
suis tant que j'y allais quand même
voilà il a tout le temps présent posé la
question parce que moi quand j'ai eu
dans le who's who knew l'adresse j'étais
très surpris l'adresse professionnelle
c'est présidence de la république 55 55
rue du faubourg nous est faux ouais
ouais je vous ai dépassé comme souvent
et toi je t'ai suite l'année donc on
vous écrit ou alors maintenant on met
clair la mairie du 13ème arrondissement
à la place d'italie
voilà très bien alors maintenant donc
j'allais écrire un janot tiberi
transmettra commencent en effet à
l'hôtel de ville ça m'arrive donc on va
vous faire une idée review alors vous
connaissez le principe on va tous vous
posez des questions bruyère aussi et
vous avez essayé de de répondre
donc j'ai demandé à serge khalfon de
faire la lumière adéquate voilà c'est
bien pour les yeux ça aujourd'hui alors
j'ai vu j'ai vu la séquence tournée
estivale dieu j'aurais bien au rendez
vous bruyère et astrid on a vraiment les
yeux vous allez prendre ne veux pas me
comparer avec brière donc ça c'est pas
possible
ça va avec bébé que jalouse
ah la la moi j'ai les yeux moi j'ai des
yeux marrons audio de cochon c'est le
manque d'accord c'est ce qui à
l'intérieur
alors donc d'abord survolé un petit peu
votre votre enfant se disant vous êtes
né en 1941 ce qui vous fait quand même
58 ans et oui mais oui vous avez bien
conservée parce que parce que c'est vrai
que c'est pas tout à fait je suis leur
plus jeune que ça c'est vrai c'est vrai
vous avez l'air un peu d'un adolescent y
masse et le mal à 10 alors votre père a
été coupée au casino de nice ensuite au
casino de charbonnières
ce qui fait que c'est elle habitait à
lyon c'est comme ça il vécu 15 ans ayant
peut-être trouvé à lyon il a quand même
terminé directeur des jeux au palm beach
de cannes donc c'est pas mal alors vous
vous êtes mariés à lyon avec la fille du
bâtonnier de lyon bat ce n'était pas
rien béatrice berne à ce corps qui a été
qui est aujourd'hui madame ce gars oui
elle est toujours madame ce gars oui on
a divorcé en 1978 et l'année suivante ou
deux ans après elle avait posé les pieds
de ses rôles savais pas ça fait chaud et
les pourquoi pourquoi les choses
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce-que pourquoi
est-ce que non mais je n'arriverai pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas
aujourd'hui la solitude c'est une
histoire les mêmes histoires crise ceux
qui ne font pas de la politique
s'il a gardé parce que monsieur seguin
il est attaché
six cordes non mais est-ce que ça
facilite vos relations avec ce gars non
moi j'ai connu finish que en 1905 de
méchantes il ya quelques années avant
donc en 74 68 vous connaissiez déjà et
bien sûr d'accord donc je suis presque
sûr c'est vous qui l'avez moi j'étais
dans les cabinets presque ça parce que
en fait il est entré au cabinet de
christian poncelet qui est aujourd'hui
le président du sénat et il y est
inscrit notamment grâce à moi qui était
à matignon à l'époque
donc oui c'est parce que ça a dit moi
jacques est ce que vous faites comme les
noix parce que bruyère nous raconter
tout à l'heure que finalement bas le
connaissent et s'il ya la première femme
de yannick tout ça se passe très bien
est-ce que vous avez ce côté cameroun et
qui consiste à faire vivre femme enfant
non c'est pas qu'à monnet on vit pas
ensemble mais et c'est simplement que je
m'entende toujours très bien avec ma
première femme qui sont en très bien
avec ma femme je crois que vais rassurer
une majorité
alors oui tout à fait alors bon on va
vite vous avez fait l'ena rejeté la même
promotion que j'ose pas et chevènement
oui qui font beaucoup plus âgée que vous
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai je pense
surtout j'espère surtout oui et alors
vous n'êtes pas sorti
classé à l'ena parce que finalement le
prof ans par le prof mais le patron de
l'ina l'époque vous a dit oui vous
auriez dû sortir dans les tous premiers
mais vous savez c'est difficile de faire
l'ena cantonniers d'une origines
sociales modestes
oui ça vaut il ma poche du chat du tout
à fait comme ça mais en gros je suis
très bien entrer à l'ena je suis rentré
5e et puis je suis sorti je crois qu'il
faut expliquer qu'il ya à la sortie un
classement et en fonction du classement
de la sortie on choisit les différentes
postes dans l'administration
c'est comme dans les autres grandes
icônes d'ailleurs mais et je ne suis
sorti que 33e c'est à dire quand j'ai
reculé pendant pendant l'école et c'est
vrai qu'on m'a expliqué que c'était
parce que j'avais pas trop le genre de
la maison
voilà votre vie a été marquée jacques
toubon par deux rencontres très
importantes
jacques chirac et votre épouse qui
s'appelle donc désormais lis tout bon
donc jacques chirac bernadette a pas été
libre de vos épouses addition donc
jacques chirac me rencontrer à 69 à la
fondation claude pompidou alors
physiquement évidemment vous ressemblez
pas du tout parce que c'est un peu don
quichotte et sancho pansa mais vous avez
quand même quelque chose en commun une
espèce de gémellité politique et vous
allez en commun vous dites lui certes ça
il dit se crever la patate et mouiller
sa chemise c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui vous qui vous caractérise la planche
et déjà été nommé secrétaire général du
rpr en 1984 dans des assists déroulés à
grenoble
une fois que j'ai été nommé j'ai fait un
petit discours d'introduction en quelque
sorte et c'est le programme que j'avais
donnée parce que deux ans après il y
avait des élections initiative 86 et
c'est le programme que j'avais donné
c'est un lyon qui connaît pas je veux y
arriver à la naissance est un aveu terry
pour un homme politique il faut mouiller
sa chemise et quand on est mouillé en
chance d'affaires
franchement vous savez lorsqu'on
travaille souvent
vraiment vraiment mouillé sur que c'est
pas mais roselyne bachelot un peu la mi
mai alors vous avez beaucoup
d'admiration pour jacques chirac vous
avez quand même dire une fois que
c'était la lumière qui guide nos pas
quoi vous souvenez d'avoir dit ça
absolument vous persistez après la après
la dissolution la mer c'est toujours la
lumière qui devait passer c'est une
image biblique
oui bon bah oui ça soit la grille mais
comme google on fait quand vous regardez
vous levez la tête noël a pas regardés
dans le guidon à voir vous en échange de
quoi on vous a quand même surnommé la
voix de son maître
non non non non non c'est charles eu
lieu le choc mais vous êtes une fidélité
absolue d'ailleurs et chirac dit en
parlant de vous si je lui demandé de
sauter par la fenêtre il le ferait ah ça
c'est vrai qu'il nous ait chauffé
peut-être chez vrai qu'ils ont bien sûr
donc c'est sûr les errements simple vous
êtes fidèle d'entre les fidèles et vous
avez maire du 13e c'est très bien mais
il y en a d'autres présentent nicolas
sarkozy qui a trahi chirac
aujourd'hui il est tête de liste aux
européennes président du rpr par intérim
alors la question c'est pour réussir en
politique faut-il trahir je crois pas du
tout je pense que je veux dire que je
suis là trahi tout le monde il est
devant vous aujourd'hui oui c'est clair
que finir le la politique comme toutes
les autres choses
c'est aussi affaire d'opportunisme bon
alors il ya des gens qui sont plus ou
moins opportuniste moi je suis plutôt
moi je suis plutôt
du genre et
aller jusqu'au bout du genre jusqu'au
boutiste alors la deuxième grande
rencontre de votre vie céline bélair
donc votre femme que vous avez
rencontrée en 1979
vous deviez divorcé depuis un an c'est
resté un an tranquille quoi
gt gt à belleville bon alors évidemment
vous vous aviez une enfance vous le
dites joindre une enfance provincial
sans éducation artistique par votre thé
pas qu'on vous a dû 14 ans bon j'étais
ce qu'on appelle un bon élève
voilà la gym tous voila et vous dites
vite mon milieu n'avait pas de goût
comme on dit quoi ces terres vous veniez
d'un d'un milieu simple liste ou bon
emphasizes bel air à l'époque était un
peu votre pygmalion on peut dire sur le
plan sur le plan culturel
c'est quand même elle qui le premier
cadeau qu'elle vous a fait déjà preuve
au départ alzheimer mythologies de
barthes et vous pour la remercier vous
aviez fait quoi de mieux qu'un petit mot
dans la boîte aux lettres et j'ai mis un
petit bout d'un goûter les dragueurs et
je suis monté jusqu'au quatrième étage
par l'escalier comme whip ascenseur
alors tout à l'heure ce parler avec vous
hier elle a fait beaucoup attendre
yannick a c'est à dire qu'il a il a dû
attendre beaucoup beaucoup avant de
prendre ce fameux vin dont on a parlé
avant de prendre ce fameux bain dont on
a parlé tout à l'heure vous avez mis
longtemps on sent le niçois mais moi
j'attends pas une question d'âge mais
yannick puis un gamin d'accord voilées
ont 79 n'était plus un gamin c'est le
chercheur du jury met un petit mot dans
un petit mot de ses toiles est très très
joli mais voilà on va passer à des
choses un tout petit peu moins drôle si
vous permettez c'est à dire que le
problème de lisser sa famille c'est à
dire que sa fille quand même ce fils de
new qui a épousé jean françois de new
dawn ont soit des new bamboo
généalogistes non non non elle a été
mise en examen donc sophie de nu dans
l'art dans la sphère de isola 2000
voilà dit ça
avec un promoteur soit dominique
bouillon avec une espèce de botton qui
donnait des grandes fêtes où on allait
en hélicoptère il faudra fixer les
stations de sports d'hiver que je
faisais je la donne il ya eu un trou de
550 millions de francs et dont 30
millions sont évanouis à l'étranger
alors la question je vous posais c'est
ça que vous aviez dit je suis jamais
intervenu dans cette affaire
ça a beau être la fille de ma femme je
suis jamais intervenu mais je voudrais
quand même que vous répondiez à ça on a
en a retrouvé sur l'agenda du fameux
bouillon donc le le promoteur immobilier
un petit mot sur son agenda qui dit
appeler jacques s'applique bouillon pour
un promoteur immobilier
c'était un nom prédestiné appelé jacques
qui voit le président du tribunal de
commerce de nice qui lui dit ne pas être
satisfaits de la solution
donc oui mais il a écrit sur son carnet
c'est voilà je vous dit vous c'est qu'il
a écrit sur son carnet vous alliez
intervenir
il a écrit sur son carnet pour saluer
les fans ça marche pas très bien il ya
écrit sur son carnet c'est tout wen
s'est rien passé
vous n'êtes jamais intervenu parce que
c'est pas parce que c'est pas mon genre
c'est tout - elles ont surtout veillé
avec une velléité sa part dit penser que
je viens à perdre
le le comportement de l'un n'est pas le
comportement de l'autre mais honnêtement
jacques toubon vous en aviez profiter un
petit peu des fêtes de boullion un peu
comme poivre d'arvor aimerait des fêtes
de botton à calvi a nié dans ces fêtes
jallier dans une même vous cuisinez vous
non non non et le utah ce que vous
pensez pas qu'il va vous dire non mais
je sais pas bon moi je pose des
questions on voit le jour cela fait dix
lots qui dit non il va pas jamais dit
non non pas du tout non on m'a jamais
posé cette question à la télévision des
questions mais je dis non c'est non
parce que c'est non le frère de lise cas
qui a construit le complexe de cinéma
place d'italie grand écran oui c'est pas
gênant ça quand votre arrondissement ça
soit le frère de votre femme qui avait
une espèce de l'île de palma d'énormes
attend la ville de paris a fait un appel
d'offres pour savoir quel serait le
groupe qui construirait cet ensemble
bien plat d'italie il y avait quatre
offres dont l'offre qui a été retenu par
mois par jury ville de paris c'était
celle de la société de bouillon vient
ensuite le constructeur cette société a
elle même fait des appels d'offres pour
retenir des constructeurs fameuse
entreprise de travaux publics et de
maçonnerie et la reprise qui a été
construite c'est une entreprise qui
effectivement s'est élevé l'air et qui
est celle qui est jeudi qu'ils étaient
de ma belle famille est-ce que entre
temps elle avait été rachetée par le
groupe dumez
voilà bah voulais quand même ça fait
beaucoup de circonstances oui j'ai
bouillon qui acquittent va construire le
cinéma ni fait appel à votre beau-frère
enfin bon je suis la famille ça fait des
circonstances
surtout qu'en plus sophie de new et
travailler la côte et bach était le
bureau d'études qui a travaillé sur cet
ensemble si maintenant je veux dire
c'est un peu familial quoi donc c'est
pas familiale parce que je suis pas
beaucoup c'est une famille très courtes
très bien bon bah voilà donc devant
qu'on passe à la suite j'en suis dingue
c'est dingue on a du mal à y croire
quand même je sais pas moi je dis pas
que je le prof je crois pas je dis que
c'est toutes les questions méritent
d'être posées sur pied une sur le sol
mais et toutes les réponses mérite
d'être fait voir et être entendu en tout
cas un et d'être entendue alors vous les
posez une question frédéric
vous voulez poser une question et
chanter la bamba keller faut utiliser la
culture c'est pas mon genre et de la
francophonie a quand il apprend que j'ai
fait d'une loi d'ailleurs en outre 94
qui était diversement oui sur les mots
français en france moi je peux résumer
ouais il monsieur toubon voulait plus
qu'on dise week end mais france on n est
plus qu on dise gangsters mais député du
val sais pas mais parce que je ne suis
pas tout à fait je suis pas aussi trême
par exemple française que les québécois
mais par exemple je vous prends un
exemple de 2,2 ce que c'est que par les
français aujourd'hui par exemple on
emploie pour l'internet email courrier
électronique
oui eh bien il ya un mot que certains
aujourd'hui on crée et qui s'appelle
courriel pour dire pourriez est-ce que
c'est pas joli courriel oui je sais bien
je connais muriel a voulu appeler mes
attentes a voulu appeler jingle ans nous
obligés de dire attendez vous continuez
vous voyez chirac vous ne connaissez pas
vous tutoyer la paille dont j'entends
bon côté
si vous êtes l'actrice si c'était
shakespeare je suis d'accord enfin c'est
pas shakespeare
bon bien pour moi ce serait plutôt alors
à ce moment là de donner envie aux gens
de lire et de se cultiver plutôt que
plutôt que d'essayer de les restreindre
de les faire chier sur des titres comme
week-end
wickens et je suis désolé mon français
apparaître des combats inutiles ça en
revanche donner envie de lire donné
envie d'aller au à l'opéra j'espère vous
l'avez fait
mais pas seulement moi j'y suis jamais
allé mais mais mais je rêverais ça ça me
paraît plus intéressant si je viens
quand même à votre dans la colonne des
plus a quand même c'est que vous avez
sauvé les colonnes de buren
ce qui est vrai ce qui pour un mec de
droite et plutôt bien parce que ce sont
bien ces colonnes voilà c'était écoutez
moi j'ai quand j'étais au ministère de
la culture
mon bureau donc au palais royal donnée
justement sur reset sur cette piste il
ya les colonies c'est non seulement une
oeuvre d'art que j'ai sauvée mais c'est
aussi vous le savez un des endroits les
plus fréquentés par les gosses
aujourd'hui dans paris il faut voir le
mercredi après midi
c'est un caractère festif absolument
extraordinaire est une pièce et on met
des sous dans le petit canal qui est en
dessous
après analyse la culture qui passera